[MUSIC PLAYING]
What was your first
computer science textbook?
I feel like it was called,
like, Java by Construction,
was my first textbook.
It was like an introduction
to programming in Java,
which I took in a freshman
coding class at Princeton.
My mom gave me a textbook when
I was about eight years old,
an introduction to Python.
And she started reading it
to me when I was in class,
and that was a
huge moment for me.
I got a textbook on MATLAB
programming, I think.
And I don't know if I ever
cracked the spine of it once.
CLRS textbook, the
algorithms textbook
that they use in the
algorithms class here at MIT--
it's definitely like a
mammoth of a textbook,
but I feel like it's sort
of a rite of passage.
I wasn't a huge
fan of textbooks.
I mostly read the
course notes that were
posted in a lot of classes.
But there's an introduction
to algorithms textbook I used.
I think it's by one of the
Kleinbergs, and Eva Tardos
as well.
And that was a great textbook.
I love that textbook.
And it's really fun,
because each problem
is sort of structured
as like a little puzzle
that you have to solve.
So that was my first
textbook that I enjoyed.
You know, I don't think I've
ever used a computer science
textbook.
When I really think through all
of my computer science classes,
maybe they assigned a
textbook, but I didn't get it.
Most of the time the problem
sets were available online.
The lectures were
all available online.
And most of what you
learn is from Googling
all the different
questions you might have,
and other people
telling you from--
maybe, I guess,
textbook-wise, Wikipedia.
Wikipedia is my favorite
computer science textbook.
[MUSIC PLAYING]